All right, so here we are buying the tracking number for our website.
We personally use car rail.
You are more than welcome to use Twilio or whatever other software you want to use.
That's fine.
I'm just showing you what we currently use for our company.
So once you make an account, very easy, you just put in your email and password.
You can actually also log in through Google.
So you're going to click on this, my account, and I believe it says E because it's evergreen.
So whatever your company's name will have that letter up here.
And then you're going to click on account settings down here under manage.
Click under all companies and you're going to create a company.
So each tracking number will have its own company and that's because let's say you
need to make a quick website for that same company.
We want everything to be very organized and under the same thing, it's very easy to search
as well.
And so we're going to create company right here.
You put the company name.
I actually made a mistake earlier.
It's called Queen Creek, not Queens Creek.
So let me just edit that up here as well.
Just really quick.
Okay.
Back to CarRail.
So actually taking that out.
So it's just going to be like the website title, city and service time zone.
This will be the same time zone as the location that you're targeting on the website.
In my case, Arizona, you're going to put the primary company phone number.
What that means is where do you want the calls coming to your website directed to?
So it will be probably the client's phone number or the secretary, whoever is scheduling
the leads phone number.
I'm just going to put a random one, okay, add users.
This is where you can actually add different users to be able to check the reporting.
CarRail also allows you to listen to the recording calls.
And then once you add it, you can create an account user that is your client if he does
like to listen to the recordings.
So you can get pretty creative here.
And then you're just going to click on create company and go to company dashboard.
CarRail will automatically take you here.
Okay.
So let's select the company that we just created, which is Queen Creek Concrete here.
Oops.
It's the other one.
We already had one.
We do like to add the state as well.
I just didn't want to create a duplicate, so that's why I didn't put it.
But usually you want to put the state as well, just so you know.
And then you're going to create number, click, I'll use it offline.
Same thing as before.
It should automatically pull whatever number you put earlier.
This is the phone number that the calls will be redirected to, number setup.
So you want to do a specific area code.
And how I picked this, I actually just Google Queen Creek, Arizona concrete, kind of like
if you were doing a due diligence and I like to see what the area codes of the main businesses
are.
It looks like it's a, this one is tricky because they're all different.
Looks like it's either 480, 480 looks like the most common one.
And then what I like to do is just stick that out and put area code because we want to look,
we want the website to look to the customers like we own the company and we're a local
one.
So 480.
So after that, you're just going to go back to Carl, type 480, which is the area code
we want.
Carl is going to show you four options and we like to check each option.
So you're going to copy, search for Google and search for all the numbers and pick the
one that looks the last, the least scammy.
And this is going to be a little tricky, but we like to make sure that we pick a number
that is going to be good for our website.
So search Google.
Okay.
Now we have all four numbers and what I mean with scammy is once you search for all four,
so this one only comes up with few, once we search it, this one looks good.
We definitely, so this one for, this is a good example.
See how this one says escort Phoenix.
We definitely don't want people to think we're associated with that.
So that phone number we're going to scratch off.
Scam alert, definitely not that one.
Some life mates.
Yeah, we probably want to go with this one.
Looks the least complicated.
So the one that ends in 2455 and then again, make sure you do this, especially for the
actual website that is going to be your asset.
And then we are going to name this Queen Creek, just like the company.
Make sure you add the state.
I know I didn't do it for the company, but that's just because we didn't want to duplicate
and you're going to add the service number features.
Make sure you add a whisper message.
The whisper message is up to you.
What the whisper message is when let's say I find the website, I need a concrete driveway.
I call your client will pick up the lead and we'll receive a whisper message before the
lead talks.
So the client knows that that's a lead that came from you.
And so we can put something like new lead from Queen Creek concrete.
So the client knows, okay, this is a lead that Nick sent me or whatever.
And then make sure you click on call recording because we want to record every call that
came through and boom, you're done.
So it's right here.
This is your tracking number that we're going to use for the website.
And then this is the phone number you're going to forward the calls.
If you ever need to change it in the future, just click on this pencil right here.
You click on the pencil again up here and you're going to be able to change who the
numbers are being forwarded to.
You can change the whisper message, you can change everything and then just make sure
you click save and you're done.